GOOD MORNING --
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR FRIDAY
AUGUST THIRTY SOMEONE CALLED
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING FINISHED
RECEIVED AS ALSO BEING TELEVISED
-- MEN OF SECTOR PLEASE
CULTURAL FULLY HERE CUNNINGHAM
OKAY FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS CELL PHONE HERE
RAMOS RIVAS YEAH WICKS
HAVE A QUORUM SAID IN A
SURVIVORS WORK SAILOR MISTER
MATHIS ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
MADAM SECRETARY IS CULTURAL
COOLING HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE PERKS OVER
SO BY ROMAN SIDE RAMOS I RIVAS
HI WHEN I
FOR ON CONSENT YES FOR I
-- THE MOST JUST PASSED AND
THIS RULES PROCEDURE THANK YOU